[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
28 septembre
les titres de cette édition c'est dans
un an la ryder cup 2018 se tiendra au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et avant
d'accueillir la coupe du monde de golf
le site reçoit le paris seul agent
championship
c'est jusqu'à samedi compétition qui
regroupe des légendes de la discipline
interview sur place au début de cette
édition
ils sont jugés inefficaces et trop
coûteux le gouvernement a annoncé cet
été la baisse des contrats aidés un
dispositif utilisé par les associations
et collectivités locales comme le
conseil départemental des yvelines qui
s'inquiètent de cette mesure
et puis lentilles prince des villes
c'est le titre de ce recueil de poésie
tout récemment publié par un saint
quentinois tristan si nos moments de vie
déclaration d'amour et engagement sont à
découvrir en verre on en parle avec lui
à la fin de ce journal
les directions tout de suite le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors fait pas encore pour la ryder cup
l'événement mondial c'est dans tout
juste un an
jusqu'à samedi le site accueille une
étape de l'european senior tour c'est le
pari ce legends championship
bonsoir ni kalemie doro vous êtes sur
place la compétition permet 54 légendes
du golf mondial
ajoutez à cela le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines qui accueillera la
ryder cup dans tout juste un an et vous
obtenez la deuxième édition du paris
sladen championships pour nous parler
nous au rendez vous qui attire les
meilleurs golfeurs de 50 ans et plus
je suis avec l'un des golfeurs rejet
sabarros qui a participé du coup à 7
promet à ce premier tour aujourd'hui
comment s'est passée cette première
journée roger mais vous devez plutôt pas
mal
il a fait
plutôt correct et puis en plus j'avais
une partie assez exceptionnel puisque je
voyais john delli et puis marie line
voilà c'est l'équipe qui font partie de
l'équipe et au type pitch and play wake
est organisée par l'antenne du sud et
alexis sikorsky et c'est un très très
beau temps en puisse jouer au national
sur ce parcours comme vous l'avez dit va
recevoir la ryder cup
le parcours était fantastique les
ouvriers font un travail énorme il a
déjà il s'est déjà améliorée énorme par
rapport à l'an dernier et je pense qu'à
la prochaine ça va être fantastique pour
ce tournoi qui arriva qui va arriver
incessamment sous peu vous sentez
vraiment une vraie évolution par rapport
à l'année dernière qui était la première
édition du coup est ce que vous sentez
que le tournoi monte en puissance
oui monte en puissance parce que d'abord
je crois que le promoteur décision aussi
et son équipe font énormément pour
justement que ça se passe très très bien
surtout pour nous pour les joueurs et
puis il ya eu deux problèmes juste avoir
le rolex et le renault qui s'est très
très bien passé et les joueurs sont
ravis parce que je discute un peu avec
et ils sont ravis de venir ici pour le
parcours fantastique et il se bat même
pour venir parce qu'on est très très
bien accueilli et le parcours elle nous
donne tout tout le bonheur de pouvoir
faire très bien ou moins bien mais bon
ça c'est ça c'est autre chose c'est le
goal par apparaître votre score
aujourd'hui qui est de +5 il est juste
là oui + 1 go way alors c'est vrai que
c'est aux parties de de la feuille du
bas de la feuille mais bon comme je dis
de temps en temps j'ai l'avenir devant
moi quand je retourne donc ça c'est pas
très grave mais je passe un très bon
moment
le parcours est très exigeant dont je me
suis planté sur deux trous mais peu
importe
j'ai fait une super partie avec ces deux
personnages immense et puis il ya plein
d'autres comme pas le bronze en ski et
en tête là moi cet essaim score
extraordinaire
je pense que tout le monde tout le monde
joue le jeu et tout le monde et tout le
monde est très très compétitif même si
on a plus de 50 ans donc
donc nous sommes à un an la raideur la
ryder cup qui sera organisée ici sur
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
est-ce que vous avez hâte de la voir
cette ryder cup ici
à 51 millions à oui biensur c'est
fantastique c'est fantastique pour nous
je crois que la fédé pascal grizot ont
fait un gros boulot pour l'avoir et et
c'est fantastique voilà on espère et moi
j'espère qu'on aura un voire pourquoi
pas deux français qui qui participa mais
cela dit ça va être beaucoup de un gros
coup de boost pour le golf français je
l'espère je fais les parcours pendant
ces trois jours de compétition où je
fais le parcours oui oui le parcours en
le ch foncé les traces comme disent
comme dirait les skis les skinheads en
prépa mais bon je pense que je pense qu
on jouera pas les mêmes coûts que les
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux vont jouer
dans un an
merci beaucoup roger savard housse et
bon courage pour demain je me rappelle
le pari les djeuns championship c'est
jusqu'à ce samedi golf national de
saint-quentin dit qu'elle profitait bien
de ce beau plateau n'a été coupé au
début de cet entretien je rappelle avec
il regroupe d'anciens grands noms de la
discipline opération recrutement à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la police
nationale était présente toute la
journée sur l'esplanade de la gare où
passent chaque jour plus de 70000
personnes
objectif informer et recueillir de
potentielle candidature trois à quatre
mille gardiens de la paix seront
embauchés prochainement sur concours
recherche de profils qualifiés et donc
mais pas que propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
on a constamment besoin de personnel et
on propose également pour des jeunes qui
sont un peu moins qualifiés qui n'ont
pas le bac qui ont peu de diplômes la
possibilité de rentrer chez nous par un
autre accès à ce sont les adjoints de
sécurité sans condition de diplôme mais
bien sûr avec les qualités requises pour
être fonctionnaire de police et 25,5
pour cent ce sera le pourcentage de la
population et binoy âgées de plus de 60
ans en 2040 importance donc que des
lieux d'accueil de seniors subsiste une
convention de partenariat vient d'être
signé à saint quentin en yvelines elle
va garantir une deuxième vie aux
méventes elle aussi du mes rentes et à
manier à les hameaux il accompagne des
personnes dépendantes les précisions de
mélanie poker
après les difficultés financières de
géronde icap l'avenir s'est éclairci au
mes rentes et une convention vient
d'être signée entre l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines et
l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation et les soins cinq ans qu'a
fait tout l'investissement nécessaire
sur surmas avec maintenant loue ses
bâtiments un prix attractif puisque
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
100 euros du mètre carré par rapport à
166 euros sur sur le marché et puis va
aider aussi au démarrage dans le
financement
ro na vi qui c'est à dire comment donc
il faut remettre aux normes à la cuisine
c'est c'est la communauté d'agglo qui va
le faire et puis après on m'a donné
trente mille euros au départ puis 20000
unimilk un financement sur trois ans
avant que le domaine deviennent
autonomes financièrement le mes rentes
et est depuis 2010 des personnes
dépendantes
accueil de jour aide à domicile ou
encore accueil des malades d'alzheimer
une dizaine de partenaires vont
travailler ensemble et là on a
absolument tout ce qui peut se faire sur
la et tout ce qui peut prendre en charge
des glissements tout ce qui peut aider à
une meilleure prise en charge du
vieillissement
non je pense que là c'est vraiment un
c'est vital la mutualisation le
transfert de compétences transfert
d'informations des expertises c'est
vraiment c'est ce qu'il faudra venir une
école d'ergothérapie doit ouvrir en
septembre 2010 8 90 étudiants seront
attendus 300 personnes devraient être
accueillis d'ici trois ans cela a créé
un appelé cet été le gouvernement a
annoncé la baisse des contrats aidés car
jugée inefficace et coûteux et les
collectivités territoriales utilise
pourtant ce dispositif pour embaucher
c'est le cas du service espaces verts du
département des yvelines qui est inquiet
de cette décision est nicolas landry et
axel de belles à cet endroit-là nous
avons les fraisiers framboisiers
groseilliers et même des cassissiers à
56 ans bernadette déborde s'occupe du
potager biologique du domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles agent immobilière
elle décide de se reconvertir dans
l'horticulture
après une formation au chef elle signe
un contrat aidé en janvier 2017 avec le
conseil départemental
je vois vraiment pas comment on pourrait
comment dire arrêter une disposition
comme celle là
parce qu'elle a quand même contribué à
ramener sur le marché du travail
beaucoup de personnes que l'on croyait
perdus entre 2016 et 2017 plus de 700
contrats aidés ont été signés par le
département plusieurs postes dans les
collèges au service espaces verts ou
dans les services administratifs ce type
de contrat c'est 20 heures de travail 6
heures de formation un dispositif devant
permettre aux bénéficiaires du rsa un
retour à l'emploi
l'intérêt c'est aussi de les former et
d'abord une formation qualifiante et si
possible une formation diplômante ci
fait qu'à la fin de son contrat avec
l'accompagnement qui activity pouvait
faire ça permettait à ces gens là de
retrouver soit un emploi soit de
retrouver une formation peut être plus
performante qui correspond à leur vrai
projet professionnel pour un contrat
aidé la charge financière mensuelle du
département s'élève à 490 euros pour
l'état elles représentent entre 300 et
400 euros par mois le gouvernement
voulant supprimer ce dispositif les
collectivités devraient compenser la
participation budgétaire de l'état
ensuite dire que ça coûte cher oui
incontestablement
mais ça ne pourra pas être porté par les
collectivités si parallèlement on
continue à retirer de l'argent en
collectivité en 2016 les yvelines estime
avoir enregistré une baisse de 9 % des
bénéficiaires du rsa
grâce aux contrats aidés et pour être
complet sur cette thématique des
contrats aidés je vous propose tout de
suite d'écouter l'interview de florence
granger et député lrm de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines
en ce qui concerne également le parcours
de formation qui doit être en principe
dans un contrat aidé il n'y a que 23 %
des bénéficiaires de contrats aidés qui
bénéficie d'action et d'heures de
formation
donc notre objectif il est de maintenir
les contrats aidés pour les publics et
les secteurs prioritaires mais deux
d'investir dans le développement des
compétences et on a un grand plan
d'investissement sur les compétences
avec un milliard d'euros dès 2018 est
depuis 1974 il coordonne et anime les 30
bureaux et point d'information jeunesse
des yvelines en octobre yvelines
information jeunesse vous propose de
trouver votre service civique
trois événements majeurs sont organisées
à travers le territoire bonsoir laurence
cousin directrice sa divine information
jeunesse vous organisez donc assez
service civique dating sur trois jeudis
du mois le 5 octobre à aubergenville le
12 octobre à nos repas et le 19 octobre
à poissy on va en parler dans un instant
mais d'abord peut-être représentons le
service civique c'est avant tout un
engagement qui est volontaire exactement
non ce n'est pas un emploi vous faites
bien de le préciser
donc on est sur un engagement volontaire
pour qui s'adresse à des jeunes entre 16
et 25 ans à voir des jeunes qui pas vers
30 ans y sont en situation de handicap
qui s'engagent sur une mission d'intérêt
général
et quel organisme peut proposer des
services publics sur quels domaines on
peut faire son service civique
alors quel organisme des services de
l'état collectivités territoriales
fondations associations
j'en oublie peut-être en tout cas voilà
garde de nombreux organismes qui peuvent
effectivement se rappelle à des
volontaires en service civique et les
jeunes pour ce service civique eux
perçoivent une indemnité c'est ça alors
que wii fit wii bien sûr ils le
perçoivent une indemnité qui s'élève à
580 euros par mois d'accord qui peut
être majoré pour les boursiers échelon 5
et pour les personnes en situation de
handicap qui gardent leurs indemnités en
parallèle alors vous organisez ca
service civis service civique dating sur
les trois jeudis du mois d'octobre donc
le 5 octobre aubergenville le 12 à
maurepas et le 19 à poissy quel est le
principe de cet événement quels sont les
objectifs derrière cette opération
alors déjà non c'est vrai que c'est un
événement d'ampleur départemental c'est
pour ça qu'on est décliné sur trois
bassins pour cueillir excessif ou les
yvelinois tous les jeunes divinement
exactement quand on n'est pas seul bien
sûr on est en étroite collaboration avec
la direction départementale de la
cohésion sociale
des yvelines qui sera de toute façon sur
les trois bassins sur les trois dates et
puis on est aussi avec l'ensemble de
notre réseau donc ça c'est vraiment une
première aussi pour nous avec les 30
dureau et au point information jeunesse
du département des yvelines est donc on
travaille tous ensemble pour que ce soit
donc un succès sur cette tendance
alors l'idée cette faciliter les
rencontres entre les organismes qui
proposent du service civique et les
jeunes alors le dating c'est exactement
ça c'est vraiment la valeur ajoutée
puisque tout au long de l'année dont le
réseau information jeunesse
bien sûr on peut les informer les
accompagner pour qu'ils trouvent la
mission qui leur correspondent
là l'intérêt cki êtes directement les
recruteurs sur place et qu'ils puissent
partir l'objectif c'est un jeune une
mission qui repartent avec la mission de
leur rêve
et qu'est-ce qu'on pourra trouver
concrètement sur place quels types de
missions alors les les thématiques en
termes d'engagement c'est vraiment vaste
c'est ça peut être aussi bien
d'éducation culture loisirs santé on a
quoi dos des clubs de sport
je vais certainement oublié thématique
ça peut être aussi développer le
numérique enfin il ya vraiment du
concret il ya trouvé sur place
même notre réseau information jeunesse
recrute aussi des jeunes en service
civique a donc à vélizy-villacoublay le
bij et le bizuth montigny le bretonneux
qui recherchent des jeunes volontaires
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir
les accompagner même on a mis en réseau
accompagne en amont donc avant le 5 12
les jeunes peuvent se rapprocher du
réseau information jeunesse pour
vraiment vraiment ciblé leurs missions
et trouver le jour j la structure et la
mission qui leur convienne questions
plus pratiques pour terminer il ce qu'il
faut s'inscrire au préalable pour
participer à ce service civique dating
les organismes on les connaît donc on a
à peu près entre dix et quinze
structures par bassin sur chaque date
ça représente à peu près deux
soumissions en tout qui seront proposés
les jeunes viennent librement de 14
heures
la fermeture c'est 18h30 d'accord d'ici
qu'ils viennent nombreux bien sûr et on
développera également l'engagement et la
mobilité européenne puis soumis à des
labels européens avec notamment le
centre d'information europe direct nous
représente dans la baie de la commission
européenne donc ont éventuellement
pourra aussi élargir les petits
d'engagement sur une mobilité européenne
n 3 dates proposées par yves une
information jeunesse le 5 octobre à la
maison des associations d'aubergenville
le 12 octobre au café de la plage à
maurepas ainsi que le 19 octobre à la
source à poissy merci laurence cause un
ancien avec nous et directrice est
divine information jeunesse et pour plus
d'informations sur ces services civiques
dating vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
c'était notre dossier de la semaine fil
rouge consacré au logement étudiant et
dernier reportage ce soir sur les offres
publiques et privées de logement en
résidence universitaire comparaison sur
les prix les services proposés sur deux
sites de saint quentin en yvelines c'est
avec nicolas landry
aujourd'hui un ça va bienvenue chez les
a' pierre-marie cette étudiante en
licence administration économique et
sociale est installé à la résidence
vauban du cros à guyancourt un studio t1
meublés loués à plus de 400 euros le
loyer très abordable et donc voilà donc
là c'est mince à leurs jours ces jours
ma salle de bains étudiant je n'ai pas
besoin de grand chose tu as vu mon lit
un bureau voilà ouverte en 1995 la
résidence vauban comporte 132 chambres
des studios t1 entre 402 et 409 euros
des t1 bis en colocation entre 329 et
332 euros en fin d'été 2 à 516 euros
il ya aussi une salle commune et une
laverie nos missions fondamentales c'est
d'appuyer l'étudiant dans la réussite de
ses études par le biais de tarifs
sociaux et aussi être des facilitateurs
du rôle social
de son brouillon de rôle social
accompagner les étudiants à organiser
des soirées mettre en place des lieux de
rencontres au sein de la résidence pour
créer une mixité sociale
c'est une volonté forte du directeur du
crous de versailles et de faire vivre
ces résidences pas seulement des lieux
de vie mais aussi des lieux de
socialisation
autre solution pour se loger se tourner
vers le parc privé avec notamment la
résidence daniel morellon espacil
filiale du groupe action logement est
spécialisé dans le logement social
elle est propriétaire et gestionnaire de
ces 154 logements des t1 entre 400 et
500 euros des t1 bis à 580 euros
dt 2 à 820 euros alors là nous sommes
dans un t1 bis donc de trois mètres
carrés le loyer de 587 euros
vous avez ici dans le t1 bis un espace
kitchenette donc avec frigo neuf sous
évier et plaques de cuisson donc assez
fonctionnel pour cuisiner ouverte le 1er
septembre 2016 cette résidence vise un
public particulier les doctorants et il
s'est avéré que au bout de quelques mois
c'était un public qui était pas facile à
capter là on s'est orienté en début
d'année sur le un public complémentaires
que nous autorisait d'ailleurs les
diverses conventions
c'est à dire des étudiants à une laverie
une salle de travail et une salle
commune les gestionnaires ont un budget
pour organiser des soirées en 2017 cinq
résidences étudiantes ont été livrés à
saint quentin en yvelines a eu en cours
ils continuent de pousser les jardins
familiaux compte désormais trente et une
nouvelle parcelle
elles ont été inaugurées le week-end
dernier avec cette extension
l'association des jardins répond à une
importante demande des personnes à la
main verte
patrick jacques de dixmude et les arènes
samedi 23 septembre les jardins
familiaux de guyancourt se sont
agrandies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit là de l'inauguration de
l'extension des jardins familiaux de
guyancourt avec trente et une nouvelle
parcelle qui ont été mises à côté du des
jardins existants et qui donc permettent
de pérenniser cette installation est
d'offrir à au plus grand nombre
officiellement loué depuis juin dernier
ces nouvelles parcelles de 170 à 200
mètres carrés vont permettre aux
locataires de laisser libre cours à leur
créativité de jardiniers en herbe je
demande conseil aux anciens qui qui me
donne pas mal de conseils il faut
planter sa à telle période ça à telle
période et voilà à quoi bon là je me
suis lancé déjà dans dans la salade
alors vous avez dit à la bataille
j'aurais très bien les fans
par contre les choux je me suis fait
manger les shows par les oiseaux
j'aurais dû les recouvrir l'association
des jardins familiaux de guyancourt
compte aujourd'hui 91 membres pour le
plus grand plaisir de son président nous
ce qu'on aime justement c'est le contact
voire tous les membres de l'association
se croiser pouvoir discuter déchets buts
et chouchouter les jardins sont loin de
là c'est les foules puisque déjà 20
cents personnes sont sur liste d'attenté
lui aussi a grandi à guyancourt on
accueille sur ce plateau triste ancien
au bon soir vous êtes donc un saint
quentinois de 25 ans vous publié chez
edilivre lentilles prince des villes
c'est un recueil d'une vingtaine de
poésie qui retrace des moments de vie
vous y parlez de votre naissance votre
famille de l'amour de votre
homosexualité aussi des textes engagés
on va y venir est la lecture l'écriture
vous avez toujours animé
vous avez participé à la création d'un
journal étudiant vous écrivent également
sur le tapis blog qui donne la parole
aux jeunes du territoire pourquoi sauter
le pas de publier votre premier ouvrage
j'avais envie d'être lu j'ai créé depuis
un moment j'ai commencé à écrire dans
mon adolescence
c'est un moment où on a tous des choses
qui nous qui bouillonne en nous des
choses qui les orages qui nous qui nous
font souffrir qui nous font sourire ses
marques et qui marque et pour moi
l'écriture a été un moyen de les
exprimer efficacement et pourquoi
choisir le moyen de la poésie justement
pour parce que l'on exécute un four
nations avec lesquelles je suis à l'aise
qui et qui permet de dire les choses
assez subtilement et d'imagés un peu
plus tôt des directement au but
alors à vous rencontrer dans le détail
le titre lentilles prince des villes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire à l'interface
des villes agression sauvage de
machiavel non non il ya une référence
avec tristan de tristan et isolde
d'accord nous suivons gratifié de
le prince on entend alors ton iso taïso
est ce que tu as trouvé ou pas d'accord
et
en fait j'ai pas du tout comme le prince
tristan la légende et appuie les villes
parce que je vis en ville une fois dans
un palais alors vous parlez dans cet
ouvrage de moments de vie
vous parlez de la famille du bonheur
mais aussi l'épisode douloureux comme
votre naissance prématurée d'ailleurs
une petite anecdote à ce sujet vous
parlez dans le dans la poésie ses
entretiens avec enzo non celle aussi des
résidences enzo j'avais perdu le titre
vous inventez en fait un frère jumeau
c'est ça vous inventer un mot alors en
fait tu signer naturellement j'aurais
tué ma mère m'avait raconté quand
j'étais petit que j'ai failli avoir un
frère jumeau d'accord qui avaient tous
quittés prévu pour accueillir un
deuxième et un ventre ne gagne pas le
bébé est donc cette idée m'avait séduit
et dans un moment où je me sentais un
peu seul et pas très intéressant j'ai
raconté un ami capitaux que j'avais eu
un frère jumeau qui est décédé à la
naissance
donc ça ça permettait d'être un peu plus
intéressant et devrait attirer un peu
plus est
la tension est au son des autres alors
vous parlez de votre famille c'est aussi
important pour vous de peut-être rendre
hommage à votre famille oui elles
certaines personnes particulièrement des
gens qui sont partis un peu trop tôt et
les gens qui
qui ont donné un coup de pouce dans la
vie alors dans l'anti prince et vais
vous parler aussi de votre homosexualité
notamment dans la poésie lui dire où
vous parlez d'une déclaration d'amour
redouter une chose qui reçoit aussi
plusieurs fois dans votre ouvrage
c'est la notion de liberté le dire pour
être libre c'est quelque chose
d'important on y suit puisque des années
pour les aînés je me suis tu ça fait
cinq ans que j'assume réellement et
c'était une grande souffrance mois de
notaire mais le jour où mon père me dit
qu il était temps d'assumer et que
c'était pas une honte
le jour où j'ai osé dire à quelqu'un que
j'étais homosexuel vous senti beaucoup
mieux mais ça a été une libération sans
libre vous le dites dans les ouvrages
des poésies aussi qu'ils sont engagés
je voulais vous parler du vin qui traite
par exemple de l'action nocifs de
l'homme sur la planète
le poète est il forcément quelqu'un
d'engagé oui oui oui souvent les poètes
fait passer des messages dans leur
époque
d'autres
profitez de leur de leur notoriété pour
changer les choses
oui pour être forcément engager un autre
exemple de poésie engagée dans regarde
qui fait référence à la france c'est le
manque aussi d'unité nationale trop
récurrent dans le pays vous dites dans
l'une des strophes regarde nous sommes
comme une famille divisée à force de se
plaindre du manque d'équité
chacun sa barque et prend son chemin et
se demandent ce que la famille sera
demain quel message voulez vous vouliez
vous passez dans ce message le fait que
chacun
ce qu'ils se réfugient dans son propre
parti dans ses propres idées et en même
temps dit que
y en a marre des divisions de faut
s'unir mais personne ne fait vraiment
pas de l'imiter mais finalement aussi
des événements comme des attentats par
exemple en france pour unir la
population française peut-être message
aussi sur la dernière partie
[Musique]
se demande ce que dément sera la famille
surtout une clin d'oeil sur le mariage
pour tous d'accord modèle moderne de la
famille a été critiqué parce que c'est
pas assez naturel est passé
conventionnel mais c'est pourtant ce qui
unit puisse finalement beaucoup de
messages dans ces trois une dernière
question très rapidement quels sont
maintenant les projets c'est peut-être
d'en écrire un deuxième opus de l'anti
france des villes oui écrire un autre
livre j'ai pas encore l'idée préciser la
forme que prendra ce serait tout aussi
engagé ajouté qu'un et bien merci
tristan sino d'avoir été avec nous vous
publiez je le rappelle chez edilivre
lentilles prince des villes un recueil
de poésie c'est disponible en librairie
et en version numérique plus d'infos sur
votre blog qui s'affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs
avant de refermer ce journal ce soir
conseil communautaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines première
séance de rentrée
mais ce sera la dernière pour le
président michel laugier élu sénateur il
doit quitter la tête de l'agglomération
contraint par la loi sur le non-cumul
des mandats le nom du nouveau président
sera connu courant octobre les élus se
réunissent ce soir à partir de 19 heures
30 au siège de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 on se retrouve
lundi pour une nouvelle semaine l'info
locale sur tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]